one of the things that I'm fascinated
with his stories like parents I like a
my own family I grew up in a very weird
family complete like one on this side
one on the complete my mother sided with
Communists my dad said they were
imperialists in Iran confusion like I
grew up in the most craziest environment
can you tell your story and I'm sinners
saying oh my gosh so your mom on one end
purely love you know she believed in you
totally you can do this go get them do
what you want to do you can do this you
can pull this off you can see this woman
your mother loves you believes in you
you can do anything wrong by your mom
and then your dad on the complete
opposite end you know where it was high
expectation you know a possible shadow
first of all for some people that don't
know where your dad is the founder of
Benihana he was a champion wrestler I
think he was doing speedboating a couple
times he almost killed myself it was a
story about him and in hot-air balloon
going from Japan to the US or whatever
broke a world record you know all these
are the things that he did he party but
he's been on Oprah Winfrey Show you know
he was on all these Tony Curtis I think
it was all these other names so you know
Muhammad Ali all these names he'd said
something one time and I'm like you know
I'm really curious how do you process
them when you watch him say that I think
one time he said I work 16 17 hours a
day Venus comes number one and number
two and family comes number three is
that what he meant
or did he say because me you know
sometimes the media takes a message and
somebody's and they kind of spin it yeah
is that what he said or is that really
what he believed he lived that way and
thank God that that my mom raised me
because I think the most important thing
is you have to be founded with that love
yet be founded with that human
connection and my dad lacked the human
connection it was very very very like
almost I wouldn't say cold but he was
very Japanese very masculine very tough
love you know and you never asked for a
thing from him you would never dare very
samurai spirit I never asked anything
from oh you oh you could it like you
know like you know I mean one of the
most important lessons I learned from
him someone that that had wealth
the opportunity had everything that he
built the one of the most important
things I got from him is that he
actually didn't give me any financial
you know like here's her payday here
like you need some help here's some
money so he never actually like gave me
those handouts and I had to learn on my
own like as if I didn't have this this
like this just insane like a superhero
kind of Rockstar you know extravagant